before we discuss how to infer ancestral
states
i will pause to mention that half a
century ago biologists constructed trees
from anatomical and physiological
properties called
characters for example here's a
toy character table for three species
where the two characters considered are
whether the species have wings or not
and how many legs the species have
so this brings us to the problem of
trying to reconstruct a phylogeny from a
character table
of course i don't need sean to swoop in
and tell us that this is currently not a
well-defined problem
in the modern era constructing a
phylogeny from anatomical characters
seems crazy in some circumstances just
imagine
trying to construct a coronavirus
phylogeny from anatomical characters
if you think for a moment about how we
would construct
an evolutionary tree from characters
then one idea you might come up with
would be to cluster all
organisms having the same character on
one side of the tree together
for example if we're considering wings
and stick insects
we should probably put all winged stick
insects on one side of the tree
and all the wingless stick insects on
the other side of the tree
this strategy is completely reasonable
and it's in keeping with an over 100
year old postulate called
dallos principle of irreversibility what
this principle states is that
evolution is efficient it doesn't
reinvent the same organ over and over
again such as insect wings
yet when we construct the sick insect
phylogeny
we see that wings were gained or lost at
seven
different times in stick insects alone
shown here by stars
when we then zoom out and construct a
phylogeny of all insects
we see that wings have been gained or
lost hundreds of times
this may seem like a mystery but what's
going on is that evolution
isn't reinventing the wings from scratch
the pathways needed for flight aren't
being eliminated completely by eroding
into pseudogenes
they're just being used for something
else in wingless species
then they're getting turned back on when
they're needed in a winged species to
accommodate flight
accordingly using genetic data as
characters
has some merits we can bypass issues
such as these
in fact if we're given a multiple
alignment then we can just
view this alignment as a character table
of its own in which
each row corresponds to a species and
each column
of the multiple alignment corresponds to
an individual character with up to
either 4 or 20 different values
depending on whether we're looking at a
multiple alignment of dna or rna or
amino acids
so the question then is how to take this
character table of sorts
constructed from a multiple alignment in
order to reconstruct
ancestral states